we already have one winner ahead of
Sunday's Grammys the advanced women's
choir at West Orange high school in
Winter Garden Florida showed us their
musical talents only on CBS this morning
we are revealing that the choirs leader
Jeffrey Redding is the winner of this
year's Grammy music educator award as we
count down two music's biggest night
Jamie wax introduces us to reading and
some of his students Jamie good morning
good morning John growing up one of four
boys Jeffery reading couldn't always
count on lots of stuff but he could
count on two things
his music and the love of his mother he
lived in a single-parent home and his
mother a school cafeteria worker had
little money but plenty of support she
taught reading that circumstances don't
make the person and now he's taking that
message and paid it forward
[Music]
the power of this quartz
[Music]
is in more than the voices of its
singers it comes from chorus director
Jeffrey Redding's philosophy what are
some of the things that inspire you that
he teaches dr. eddying um he's very
adamant about passion and purpose and
making sure that everyone is accepted
are there lessons in what you do to
unify different people that spill over
way beyond use oh absolutely the first
thing is when a student walk into your
room their people do you treat them as
equals the first thing you may see is
someone's color or someone's weight
someone's this that and the other
but when they seem you see the spirit
spirit like the one in senior Darby
Weston who first met reading as a
freshman I want to hold back I can hear
his voice in my head kind of like don't
you gotta show them who you are and what
you're about so don't hold back okay if
I'm gonna cry I'm gonna cry like if I'm
not gonna cry okay if I'm gonna be
emotional about this I better be
emotional about it
the way that I want to be and be
unapologetic about how I feel
Bravo growing up already wanted to do
was sing take it but when he got his
chance to conduct as a graduate student
he found a new color and a way to give
back what we see when we watch you
interact with your students is a man who
is built a for me yes and I got that
from my mom raising four boys by herself
she taught us that regardless of what
goes on the outside you can be the very
best version of yourself
he's now passing that on to his students
you really are creating a continuation
of a tradition of selflessness anyway I
am nothing without them I can't make
chair same serving his students to honor
his mother has there been a moment where
you have felt like yes I've made my
mother proud the way I wanted to know
you ever gotten there yet no no the best
way I can make my momma proud is saying
if it's sacrifice that you made for your
boys um thank you I can I can't repair
I can't that's all I can do and
hopefully serve others how she served us
listen to the chorus they'll tell you
he's done just that all the work that he
put into me my goodness
is not gonna be lost and um I just want
to be able to give him all my love and
support
and always be able to be that for him
like he was for me she's given me my
identity that's what he's good at me
that's a single greatest thing he's
given me my identity I love those kids
and this of relationship is bond now we
get to share it with the world dance
ain't impressed he seemed to inspire
[Music]
okay Jeffrey ready I mean incredible
teacher of the year Peter of the decade
I mean we're all so lucky in this job to
talk to luminaries and leaders I don't
find anybody more inspiring than these
great teachers and how humble he is to
say that he can't make a chair sing yet
right students obviously their beautiful
voices that he has working in unison but
then to hear them talk about him
somebody when somebody says he gave me
my identity oh my god it's the dream for
a parent to have a teacher read your
child like taking about his mother in
that way who raised four boys all by a
hair by herself saying she taught us
that regardless of what goes on the
outside you can be the very best person
yourself and he's still working on
wanting to make her proud that's what
I'm struck by what's beautiful is when
he spoke about his mother and was
exactly the same tone the same terms
that is well deserved for him right well
absolutely big night what a great piece
thanks John this to me and you thickened
mom to the ground we'll see I think so
okay you can watch those Grammys the
61st Grammy Awards Sunday February 10th
right here on CBS